kyle right off probably his best start
of the year six and a third against the
mets last time out
a hit a walk six strikeouts in 98
pitches he was really good
another ground ball three for three is
right a perfect one two three opening
inning against the red sox couldn't have
drawn it up any better
the red sox starting pitcher tonight
chris mazza this is his sixth start
what a lot of opportunities he has had
ronald lacuna junior leading off
swinging and a high fly ball that's
wallop deep left
ronald lacuna junior bent flip it's
bombs away
one nothing a lead off home run
we told you seeing almost five pitches
per plate appearance he saw
five and the fifth one left the park in
a big hurry yeah i mean he's just trying
to make the other pitcher work a little
bit before he takes him deep now so
make him get into the count a little bit
man that was
loud that that ball was loud that was
smoked
ronald lacuna junior's 19th career
leadoff homer
oh baby yeah i don't know if that was a
cutter or a slider but
in any event it was middle middle and
those do go far
can't blame him for admiring that one
can't wait for the tail of the tape
chris mazza had a one two three second
wave and a miss 81 miles an hour put him
away
all these fans and they're two down
samaza putting ozuna on with a walk but
now jumps in front of duvall
and the 02. he struck him out throws him
there
mazza has struck out five he just
stranded two braves in the home third
the braves leading one to nothing as we
go to the fourth inning and how about
that
back to back pitches strikes out jd
martinez it's 12 up 12 down kyle right
perfect through four
jackie getting his second rip at right
he has grounded to the pitcher over one
stings that one is center field acuna
will watch this one fly
it is gone and a splashdown out there
that's a fine way to break up ain't no
hit bid
2-0 change-up bridge back wall in a
heartbeat
you see acuna just turned around and
looked at it
hit that back wall that's his best bolt
by far this year
number six for jackie back wall
three straight walks has kyle wright and
the braves in trouble in the seventh
hits that ball sharply tremendous play
there at first base
by riley to get the out there the run
comes in to score
that gets by him that's multiple runs
red sox do take a 2-1 lead on the ground
out
as jbj touches home what a play by riley
that's a big defensive play there that
could have been the game
that ball gets down the line three runs
probably score on this
little spinner right there riley makes a
nice play diving to his uh
left gets up tags the bag only gives up
the one run that could have been a game
breaker
and ball bees got plunked he went down
at a heap
sharply hit and throw for a base hit
ozuna's got his second knock
ozzy's gonna try for third here comes
the throw it is off target
ozzie never stopped running sore calf at
all
he goes first to third on a single to
left and chavis's throw was not good
2-0 count and another hit batsman duvall
takes one off the left arm
man oh man it's target practice and the
braves are getting plunked
webber ready a brave at every base and
dansby strikes out on three pitches
wow oh one pitch he is grounded to the
right side diving stopped by dolbeck
weber is over to cover he flips
underhanded and somehow the red sox
escape it
webber plunked a pair and gave up a hit
the braves will leave them
loaded marcakis at third echeveria at
second
lacunae junior at first hard hit ball
base hit
one run is going to score here comes a
danny around third
he's going to score aconia to third and
ozona comes through with two outs
and puts the braves in front boy do they
need that
well they've been knocking on the door
all night not able to do anything but
marcel changes that fastball up in the
zone and he is just such a good
fastball hitter on the ground slowly
toward third devers has it throws on the
run low throw got away
a run is in ozuna on his way to third
the braves get some insurance on a bad
throw from rafael devers
dulbeck couldn't scoop it up and the
braves have scored three times in the
eighth inning thank you very much
trying to put the socks in front with
two down here in the 10th
and a line drive at a right field that's
going to drop down for a hit
here comes verdugo into score and the
red sox have the lead back
and it's plawecki again to make it 5-4
first and third for the red sox
and that's a shot into center field and
another run
here comes martinez and the red sox get
a little bit of wiggle room
no balls into strike
line driving left field that's going to
get down for a hit acuna is going to be
waved around
third the throw is terrible it's halfway
up the first base line
ozzy albee's with an rbi single and the
braves get a run back
it's six to five driven
toward right verdugo on the run still
going back that ball is off the wall
high
game is tied dansby swanson with a
double as the braves were down to their
last strike
he does it again
that's a liner in the center field and
ciarte will make the catch
tagging up bank coming on in to score
rafael devers and the red sox are back
in front seven to six
freddie shoots one deep toward left
center field that ball is headed to the
track to the wall and it's gone
freddie freeman walks us off an opposite
field two-run homer the braves have
beaten the red sox for the fourth
straight time and with that home run
clinched the second seed in the national
league playoffs